Це електробус Е19 виробництва львівськогоконцерну "Електрон".
У Львові він один єдиний.
Так само як і по цілій Україні.
Е19 курсує Львовом уже три роки.
Водій електробуса Володимир Гусар знає його як свої п'ять пальців.
Каже, іноді електроніка підводить,
але загалом усі неполадки можна швидко усунути.
Колись Володимир працював водієм тролейбуса.
Тепер - не приховує задоволення від їзди на електробусі.
Я на трасідоїжджаю350 км
на одній зарядці. По місту це - на дві зміни хватає.
Володимир вважає, що одного електробуса у місті замало.
Але більше і не буде.
Принаймні в наступні два роки міська влада Львова
е планує переходити на електробуси.
Навпаки - збирається оновити зношений автопарк міста
новими дизельними автобусами.
У цьому і наступному році планують закупити не менше 200 автобусів.
Немає економічного обґрунтування використання електробусів.
Вони вдвічі дорожчі, ніж автобус.
І термін експлуатації батареї ще не такий великий,
щоб він міг мати нормальну окупність.
ЕлектробУс коштує в різних комплектаціях
від 300 до 350 тисяч євро.
а підрахунками виробника, різниця вартості
дизельного автобуса і електробуса компенсується за 5 років
за рахунок менших витрат на експлуатацію.
Короткий приклад: для того, щоб на зміну виїхав дизельний автобус
і проїхав зміну за день , потрібно 2 500 гривень.
Щоб зарядити в нічну зміну електробус, на всю зміну
достатньо200гривень.
З моменту випуску Е19 "Електрон" відвідали багато делегацій
з різних регіонів України.
Щоправда, до контрактів з українськими містами справа так і не дійшла.
І з огляду на фінансові ресурси громад,
навряд чи дійде, нарікають на "Електроні".
Тут бачать вихід у прийнятті державної програми
закупівлі електротранспорту в Україні.
Потім цей транспорт роздавати по містам,
заключати договори з громадами
на фінансовий лізинг,
навідтермінування громадам на 5-10 років.
Львів’яни дивуються, що їхній Е19-
єдиний український електробус і вважають,
що бум електробусів в Україні ще попереду.
Наші люди не звикли заощаджувати, економити. От і все.
Ще не дійшли до цього.
Я думаю, що сьогодні він перший,
а завтрабуде20-30,
а потім усі будуть.
У Незалежній асоціації"Електрокарс" припускають,
що тема переходу на електробУси постане не раніше, ніж через 5 років,
і, ймовірно, насамперд для міст, де ще немає розвинутої
тролейбусної і трамвайної інфраструктури.
Поки ж львівський "Електрон" продаватиме свій Е19 за кордон.
Наразі вже є пакет замовлень на наступні три роки -
у Колумбію, Єгипет, Шрі-Ланку і країни Центральної Європи.
У2019-му тут планують випустити
перші 100 електробусів, а в 2020-му - 300.